foreign
we are back for everybody's favorite
segment with nobody's favorite music
facts are your friends let's do it Joe
oh gosh
still no Kelly like literally one job as
a producer is to have not terrible music
oh trust me there are so many other jobs
and I've told you before we're going to
just chill all right
I don't do good at chili oh I'm fully
aware of that I don't either so I get
that not one of my spiritual gifts and
it's kind I think when a woman tells a
man hey just chill it's kind of like
when a guy tells a girl just calm down
calm down just calm down and no one in
the history of the world has ever calmed
down by being told that not one time
all right let's go to this article that
you handed me Kelly
I'm so thrilled about this actually
right when I saw the title hemorrhoids I
went to got some Preparation H which
should sponsor this show because I give
them so much free air time and here it
is I was at a CBS News so we know it's
factually correct
teens turning to tick tock for mental
health advice are self-diagnosing
oh man
um a third year psychology student says
this if I'm trying to figure out how to
do something I feel like it's easier to
go on tick tock
so just I want everyone to catch how
quickly the world has shifted
I went to college
um in the late 90s and in in the 2000s I
went to college and I paid a professor I
paid the university who then paid the
professor for the knowledge that was in
their head now granted I could have gone
to the public library like good hunting
says I could have done that but
there was information in my professor's
heads that I did not have access to and
I was paying for that access and in fact
there's some old colleges I think Oxford
there's several called that you can't go
into the building you can't go into the
psychology building unless you're a
major you couldn't go into the
architecture building unless you were a
major they protected the information
because that's what these students were
paying for and this was a special
incubated world and then the internet's
hit and then very quickly it was about
two thousand I don't know several years
ago
I ordered my wife backed up and knocked
the side mirror off the car and so in an
old Prius and so I got on on eBay and
bought one had it shipped to the house
my dad came my dad's um good at fixing
stuff and so we went out to fix it
together
as we're walking outside in the dark he
says into his phone
repairing 2010 passenger side mirror
Prius
um video and I was like oh gosh my old
man's losing it and then YouTube pops up
the video the exact step-by-step thing I
was like oh man
I don't really need what's in a
mechanic's head anymore I can get this
there may be some tools I don't have
there may be some like time I don't have
the time to fix this thing or there may
be some expertise I don't have a lift or
whatever
but the days win like I would go to a
mechanic and say I don't know what's
wrong I don't know how to fix this thing
that's over because I can get that
information on YouTube now
and in just a few short years it's gone
from YouTube which is millions and
millions and millions and millions of
people doing things and uploading their
process they just put up cameras and say
I'm going to give this information to
the world for free some of it's trash
and garbage much of it's great a lot of
it's just great stuff
um I built a uh compost box over the
weekend I got the plans off YouTube I
just punched it in I'd have to pay for
it I mean it's just a wild New World
we're in and I don't think we fully
grasped it and then you go one step
further to tick tock which takes an
eight minute video or a 25 minute video
or maybe even a three minute video and
turns it into a 30 second 15 second clip
now here's where this is dicey I put
stuff on on Tick Tock so I've got a I'm
a part of this system let me tell you
why
um for those of you who are not
um people of Faith there's an old story
in the Old Testament
um
by a guy named Jonah right and anybody
knows Jonah but he got eaten by a fish
and yada that's not the important part
of the story at all the important part
of the story is
there was a group of people that The
Story Goes God wanted to save and he
said those are terrible people I don't
want anything to do with this system I
don't want to be a part of this thing
they're not worth saving and he was told
that's exactly where I want you
and so that story is always resonated
with me is when people are hurting when
people are struggling people I don't
like that's where I need to go
when there is a system that I don't that
is just full of garbage I need to head
into that not run away from it not thumb
my nose and be like so
I have such disdain for 17 year olds
getting on social media platforms and in
30 seconds Googling what some diagnostic
is and being reductive and saying I feel
this and this and so I have this and you
have this too here's what you need to do
have warm lemon water and some essential
oils and your depression will just go
away
that is so dangerous
I've entered into that world to try to
bring some sort of Sanity to it and I
know people with wisdom and experience
and the right credentials have done that
so I want to call that out I've headed
into Tick Tock so it's weird for me to
be talking about how dangerous I think
all this stuff is and what nonsense this
is but the idea is the article says
social media therapy
she was diagnosed this woman was
diagnosed with anxiety and depression by
the time she was in fifth grade she was
had begun having suicidal thoughts even
with therapy her struggles with anxiety
and thoughts about self-harm made her
feel alone
there was no one I thought could help me
and I started looking for other people
through social media that I looked
through Instagram any social media could
then tick tock on Tick Tock the hashtag
mental health has been searched more
than 67 billion times
67 billion times now getting traction is
referred to as social media therapy
they're going into these spaces to the
soothe themselves to make themselves
feel better to make themselves the
master of that environment when they
don't feel that they've mastered the
environment of the outside world let me
repeat that in English when you go
scroll and you feel like you feel a
little bit better you get some super
quote or something like yeah
and you don't take that quote to the
real world you just sit there and baste
in it you'll feel better but you're
feeling better in a fake fantasy world
it's not real
because as soon as you move into the
real world and the your parents
relationship or your mom being upset
with you or your in-laws deciding what
you do Christmas or your spouse is
looking at pornography instead of
talking to you like those things are
real and what happens is we go to these
devices to get these little quips and
get these little Clips to make ourselves
feel better oh I've got this diagnosis
I've got this issue this 22 year old
influencer told me I have a thing and
it's this and this is why and I'm just
gonna stay here and then the algorithms
learn is what you like and it just keeps
pumping it in and pumping it in and now
you are sitting in a trash can swimming
and sewage
while the world spins outside
the real world just keeps spinning
outside of of this little
digital box
it says this
um as you look through Tick Tock the
algorithm strengthens it turned into
diagnosis turned into other things like
ADHD borderline personality disorder and
more depression anxiety
I'll read this last one in one recent
study by the center for counseling
countering digital hate researchers
posed as 13 year olds and searched and
liked mental health videos they found
that Tick Tock pushed potentially
harmful content to these users on an
average of every 39 seconds
harmful information wrong crap
and listen to me when you're playing
with mental health you're playing with
life and death
you're playing with long-term damage to
people
some users received recommendations for
Content about suicide within 2.6 minutes
of joining the app
what's online is a free-for-all and
there's really no accountability for
this and there's no responsibility taken
here's the last one
Canadian Journal of Psychiatry of
popular Tick Tock videos about ADHD 52
were deemed misleading one out of two
so what do we do with all this
I want to Circle back to you moms and
dads get these devices out of your
children's hands stop
cannot get mad at a 13 year old or a 15
year old or a 12 year old or a
nine-year-old for not wanting to talk to
their parents about something fine
they're kids I'll give them that
but I put the blame squarely on Mom and
Dad for handing these devices and saying
here Run free and if you have any crazy
Converse like oh what's oral sex you
know instead of asking somebody who
might know I'm just gonna google it I'll
just look on uh Tick Tock hey what's
depression I feel bad
um mom was mean to me today because I
got a D in class because I didn't study
um
I'm gonna get on Tick Tock oh I've got
depression I've got major depressive
disorder and my mom's got narcissism
person narcissistic personality disorder
this is what and now we're off to the
races and then you tell a friend at
school and that friend says hey I've got
something for you and the Hanya Xanax or
the Hanya Adderall they hand you
something else and the percentage of
that crap that has fentanyl in it is
it's it's just a whole domino take the
phones back take your kids lives back
stop sending them to tick tock
stop allowing them
and if all the propaganda bullcrap is
true about other countries running Tick
Tock and trying to dude what are we
doing
this whole thing there are people out
there trying to debunk misinformation
and good for them I'm trying I'm trying
you notice I don't talk a lot about
Diagnostics I talk more about how to
treat people how to take care of people
but at the end of the day
I think this is a really simple solvable
problem and that means our kids are
going to be mad at us for a season
they're not going to like us that's fine
that's that's our job as parents is not
to be liked all the time our job is to
protect their kids and we have to take
this crap out of our kids hearts and
Minds
we have to be adults that are likeable
that give them an opportunity to come
back and talk to us they are desperate
for adults to say hey I love you I like
you
I'm likable
what's going on in your world
they're desperate for it moms and dads
start showing up enough with the digital
babysitters
enough
let's take back our kids